barack obama beginning yet another round
of softball interviews to promote
a whopping 768-page book
and is rewriting history all along the
way anyway it goes on 60 minutes and
barack compared the president to a
dictator
while lamenting the lack of quote
institutional norms
all right barack time for a quick
hannity history lesson in fact it was
you
who targeted journalists that's right
because remember 2013 revealed your
administration
secretly spied on journalists including
then fox news reporter colleague james
rosen
uh you want to talk about institutional
norms
barack because how about spying on an
incoming administration framing michael
flynn
using a fake hillary clinton bought and
paid for russian disinformation dossier
to spy on a candidate a president-elect
and then president trump
to fuel a russia hoax because barack
i don't remember you or frankly any
democrat
speaking out about that save us the
lectures barack and where was your voice
when it was needed four years
your party never accepted election
results four years never-ending
harassment
unprecedented and your party and you
your silence was deafening so your
feigned outrage today
pretty meaningless to everyone except
maybe for the sycophants that actually
may buy
that 768-page boar
and by the way did you hear one question
from scott pelley
uh about any of that no crickets
uh any questions about russia no ukraine
no quid pro quo joe no zero experience
hunter no
lawless acts violence uh against police
defunding the police
abuse of power corruption the biggest
one in the history of the country
not a word the mob the media the
democrats they're all
united as one and are no longer
interested and have not for a long time
been interested in getting to the truth
facts or any serious investigation and
they take on the broadest hypocrisy and
double standards
all right joining us now former alaska
governor sarah palin
you know governor i'm looking at what
man you're living in barack's head i
thought for a while i lived in barack's
head because he kept mentioning me for a
while during
you know his run for office and
through palin it seemed as if the dark
spirits that had long been lurking on
the edges of the modern republican party
xenophobia
anti-intellectualism paranoid conspiracy
theories coming from the democrats so
that's a rich statement
antipathy toward black and brown folks
was finding their way to center stage
and she had no idea what the hell she
was talking about all right
and i'm like um didn't they peddle the
conspiracy theory on russia for
nearly four years yeah that's true there
um
barack obama with his uh 700 some page
promised land book i guess evidently he
thinks that he is one to lead us to the
promised land so let's refer to him as
moses
moses is the master of the politics of
personal destruction
which people were so fed up with that a
movement began
and they elected someone to hopefully
get us on a path to get rid of that
politics of personal destruction but
barack obama he just doesn't get it
first of all personally sean
um in order to let a man's opinion hurt
well you have to give a little bit of
value
to that man's opinion so i'm i'm good
there because
no i he does not represent truth
you know but there are 72 million people
this is a record for any republican
to ever get in an election all right
raise their thin margins
and when he he was elected twice and
when he
you know when you hear smelly walmart
trump supporters and irredeemable
deplorables or
back when you're running bitter
americans that cling to god guns
second amendment bible religion i think
it's revealing because what is he saying
about we the people
that it seems like it's against any
american that doesn't support him
or his views which are radical
right and i think that the the media the
lane stream media has been pretty
successful
in trying to make this whole issue an
issue of
attacks on donald trump and his
personality
or his tone or his mannerisms whatever
but really america has to remember that
the left led by barack obama and um
still hillary clinton
and by they're after us they're after
those who
yes they call us deplorables and chumps
and bitter clingers and
all all that they're after what it is
that we represent what i hope it is that
we represent
because i want to represent it is truth
and that is what barack obama is so
absent from embracing because of his
false accusations and his
his unfounded criticisms there's proof
after proof after proof that
that he is um a purveyor of untruths our
country has to love truth we have to be
seekers of truth we have to be willing
to follow truth
and there are so many untruths that
barack obama
is leading people towards still for
instance
a truth is that only law and order will
usher in peace and prosperity the
sanctity of life
that that is the truth is that we should
protect life uh the democrats platform
is
the antithesis of that the provisions
about um it's okay to kill
a baby in the womb um there are so many
things
that barack obama stands for still and
he just
doesn't get it that the solution to our
problems in this country
it all comes down to simply loving truth
he does not represent nor love truth
all right governor good to see you again
thank you for being with